President Trump says the u.s. is very
close to a highly anticipated trade deal
with China president met yesterday with
China's top trade negotiator at the
White House but he says there is still
ways to go the two sides hope to resolve
differences over certain tariffs and
American claims of Chinese cyber theft
this comes as the FBI looks into why a
Chinese woman entered president Trump's
mar-a-lago resort The Secret Service
says she was carrying a device with
computer malware Secretary of State Mike
Pompeo joins us this morning to talk
about a lot of different hotspots around
the morning world world good morning
secretary how are you it's great to be
with you first let's talk about
mar-a-lago Chinese woman goes into the
president's private club she's got four
cell phones
she's got malware is this an act of
espionage so I can't talk about the
details of the incident there's an
active investigation taking place but I
think this tells the American people the
threat that China poses the efforts that
they're making here inside the United
States not only against government
officials but more broadly it's one of
the topics that's being discussed in
these trade negotiations the theft of
American intellectual property is a big
business to the tune of hundreds of
billions of dollars and President Trump
is determined to push back against it I
mean China stealing hundreds of billions
dollars worth of property from us that's
right can intellectual property that is
they come in take it through software
companies that do business in China they
just flat-out steal it it's been going
on for decades first president to
actually take it seriously as president
Trump and a secretary my new Chilean
ambassador light eyes are doing their
best to get an enforcement mechanism so
this will stop and is the woman who was
arrested in Merrell ago connected to
that effort can't say anything about
that particular incident but it's being
looked at closely yes ma'am
how are we fighting back a bank against
that Chinese threat because you've
described as a threat to our democracy
from the Chinese it very much is they
very much want to undermine our Western
values the rule of law transparency all
the things that we hold most dear China
has a different values that look they're
an important trading partner we have
Kansas we sold a lot of products into
China we want that President Trump wants
that too but we have to change the
relationship in a way the
is fair that it's reciprocal that
they're not stealing our stuff and push
back against them whether the threat is
in the South China Sea the threat is to
our intellectual property or the threat
is of their espionage here inside the
United States this week the 70th
anniversary of NATO probably the most
important alliance in the world and I
know you addressed a number of the
ministers and warned about this Chinese
threat as well as Russian aggression
the latest Russian aggression of course
in Venezuela when is there going to be a
resolution to that salute that situation
so it was great to have all the foreign
ministers from now 29 nations that make
up NATO it was an important meeting to
both celebrate 70 years of success but
to take the mantle from the founders the
threats have changed I was a young
soldier patrolling they then East German
border the threat from Russia today is
different the threats to NATO from China
today are fundamentally different and
that's what we spoke about
that's for Venezuela this administration
is engaged in helping the Venezuelan
people restore democracies is something
they're demanding it's something Latin
America I'm gonna head to the region
before too long I'm gonna go visit some
of the great partners and allies that
the State Department has built out who
are each is determined as we are to
restore democracy there when a good turn
now to North Korea because you have been
heavily involved in this you've met more
with Kim Jong and the leader than just
about anybody else president Trump's
second summit with the North Korean
leader failed to produce an agreement to
declare and denuclearize their nuclear
weapons will there be a third summit
with nuke with North Korea I'm confident
there will be when I don't know soon I
hope so look we came out of Hanoi with a
deeper understanding of each other the
positions that the two sides had the two
leaders were able to make progress in
that respect we didn't get as far as the
world is demanding these are global
sanctions that are on North Korea today
disappointed its the negotiation and
we've always known this was going to
take a while so I don't know that I was
disappointed you always hope you'll make
progress faster better you know that in
every interaction you have we're
determined I'm convinced the North
Koreans are determined as well Chairman
Kim has promised me his promise
president Trump II will denuclearize now
it's the mission of my team to make sure
that that happen
and so this is gonna really come to a
head next week again because the
president of South Korea moon jae-in is
coming to the White House to meet with
President Trump and you will you agree
to some easing of economic sanctions to
continue the momentum on these talks
with the North Koreans president Trump
has been unambiguous our
administration's policy is incredibly
clear economic sanctions United Nations
Security Council sanctions will not be
lifted until we achieve the ultimate
objective that we set out now almost two
years ago it's my understanding that the
South Koreans are really pushing the
u.s. to try and open some of these
economic sanctions you know the case of
manufacturing Park the reopening of
tourism in North Korea they want to
continue this and you're saying the u.s.
is gonna say no we're not going there I
talked to my South Korean counterpart a
lot she's a delightful capable Minister
for their country
they're neighbors with the North Koreans
many North South Koreans have family
members there I understand the sentiment
but they've been great partners and
we've worked closely together to enforce
these sanctions we appreciate what
they're just give the context of why I'm
asking that question is because it's my
understanding the South Koreans are
pushing for that because the diplomatic
channels have gone cold have the
diplomatic channels gone cold nope
they're still open yes with the North
Koreans yes between the u.s. and the
north yes and the south and the north
yes those diplomats we we've had
conversations after Hanoi about how to
move forward and again the significance
of next week April 11th a day that the
South Korean president will meet with
with President Trump it's a big day in
North Korea's my understanding that Kim
jong-un is going to give a big speech
there what are you watching from in that
speech are we expecting some sort of
surprise out of North Korea next week
it's a big day it's something that's an
annual event where the leader of North
Korea speaks to his people will watch
very closely way he says I don't expect
there'll be great surprise but I do hope
that he will share his sediment his
sentiment that says we I believe as the
leader of North Korea I believe the
right thing to do is for us to engage
with the United States to denuclearize
our country and that we'll have a
brighter future for the North Korean
people we hope that's what he'll talk
about with his people and we'll be
watching it very closely one
really quickly about Saudi Arabia it has
been six months since the murder of
Washington proposed calmness Jamal
khashoggi this week we saw the first
pictures also out of Riyadh of what is
Saudi Arabia's first nuclear reactor
it's close to completion is the u.s.
going to allow Saudi Arabia to become a
nuclear power
we work closely with the Kingdom of
Saudi Arabia over the two years of this
administration on this very issue I
can't tell you that where the
negotiations that because they're still
ongoing but make no mistake about it we
only wish that the previous
administration had taken that threat
seriously with respect to the Islamic
Republic of Iran I cut a deal that puts
Iran on a path towards nuclear weapons
we will not I will not permit that to
happen we will not permit that to happen
anywhere in the world the president
understands the threat of proliferation
we will never write a hundred fifty
billion dollar cheque to the Saudis and
hand them over the capacity to threaten
Israel and the United States with
nuclear weapons
never Secretary of Pompeo thank you so
much for joining us this morning and
we'll be right back you're watching CBS
this morning
[Music]